coronavirus restrictions are forcing
more gigantic job losses in this
country's Macy's Kohl's and gap announce
widespread furloughs yesterday leaving
most of their workers without pay CBS
News business analysts as Jill
Schlesinger joins us now to discuss that
Joe we were talking about Macy's in the
room everybody I know has been there
just a unscientific poll in this room
where's Andre in one corner Kenton and
another Alexis we've all been to Macy's
and we knew that they were in financial
trouble but do you think that they can
now survive this pandemic I can't
imagine a world without Macy's I know
and Bloomingdale's which they also own
and you know when you think about it
what they have done is I think probably
tried to create a survival plan and that
means furloughing these hundred
twenty-five thousand people just an
enormous number of people but they also
had borrowed money prior to this move so
about a billion and a half dollars from
their credit lines they canceled orders
they stopped paying dividends to their
shareholders what they should at which
they should have done they say this is
what is necessary to ensure that they
can survive the pandemic so we also
mentioned coals and gap in that lead
introducing you do you see other retail
stores following suit sooner rather than
later absolutely you know there are
about 600 30,000 retail outlets that are
shuttered right now in the month of
March and the National Retail Federation
says that they're going to lose
something like over 400 billion dollars
so absolutely l brand so Victoria's
Secret the they own the Victoria's
Secret and Ann Taylor and every single
one of these retailers is going to be
forced to do this because otherwise they
are going to be behind the eight-ball
remember the retail industry was
suffering already last year ninety three
hundred store closures twenty three
bankruptcies that was when the economy
was good
so imagine the pressure they're under
right now I know so what advice do you
have for furloughed employees a lot of
them are listening to you right now yeah
I've heard from a lot of them they're
sending me emails number one of course
you're furloughed that means you can
actually apply for unemployment
benefits in your state so go ahead and
do that and of course prioritize those
bills food first shelter comes next but
really foods your priority and I would
say this although you hope you're going
to be rehired and Macy's hopes and all
these retailers hope they're gonna bring
these folks back I would be looking for
a job in all those places where there
are job announcements whether it's a
Walmart or Amazon or Dollar General or
CVS I think the act of looking gives you
some sense of control over a situation
which really is out of control for all
of us
so even if you just looked and stay
engaged I think that
mentally that's a good move for
everybody you know we already know how
bad the weekly jobless numbers are and
now the st. Louis Fed is forecasting
listen to this number Jill as many as 47
million people could be unemployed
does that make sense to you well I saw
that report yesterday I love the
researchers at the st. Louis Fed they do
tend to be somewhat curmudgeonly as many
economists are here's what I think we
know we're going to see weekly claims
come in in another staggeringly high
number we will get monthly claim monthly
jobless numbers on Friday and this month
for the month of March the numbers are
not going to look so bad maybe a loss of
about a hundred fifty thousand jobs
still that would snap a more than nine
year winning streak the job situation is
going to be getting worse and worse at
least for the next few months while I
hope it doesn't get up to that thirty
percent number most of the economists
that I speak to really do expect us to
peak at ten twelve maybe fourteen
percent my hope is that this will be
short-lived but I don't want to pin this
on hopes we all have to prepare for the
worst
I know that's hard to do but we'll get
through this that is hard to do and I'm
thinking of you're calling them
curmudgeonly I bet they'd like that Jill
thank you very much I know you'd mean it
with great affection I know I know thank
you very much